let's talk to the chief executive of
IMAX who helped organize the Charities
letter which was sent to the home office
Jenny Regan joins us now
um Jenny first of all any response from
the Home Secretary
I had to just check with your producer
what was happening with the Home
Secretary because it's been obviously a
day of breaking news um nothing is yet
but the very reason we've written this
letter or brought this letter together
is because we feel that she should be
listening to the Charities the
organizations who have to live with the
the home office policies day in day out
um the massive backlog in Asylum cases
which is really causing people
immeasurable harm and as we've seen very
kind of very starkly with the with the
situation in manston this week
there are no quick fixes to this issue
either we've spoken to various border uh
Force officials and previous border
Force workers over the day here on Sky
News and as used as you point out that
the size of the backlog and the number
of people that are coming across over a
thousand just in one day over the
weekend it this is this is not a
situation that anybody could can wave a
magic wand over is it it's not
um but there are you know the letter
calls for a fairer and more more kind of
workable Asylum system at the moment
um ever since Theresa May kind of coined
the
um the term hostile environment all the
home office policies have been around
um deterring people from getting here
we've seen the Rwanda policy which is
both incredibly expensive um inhumane
and in workable when actually there's
been no Focus going on on what what's
already happening the people that are
already here
um people are waiting two years or more
for deciding decisions and the reason
we've written this letter and the reason
people have signed is that they see day
in day out the kind of the issues and
and the poverty faced by those just
waiting for decision and people can't
work when they're waiting for an Islam
decision which means that they're forced
to live um of course basically for the
government or for the home office to pay
for accommodation
um but they're also forced to live in
poverty and in limbo and we just really
asking that the Home Secretary begins to
listen to those who have lived
experience of Asylum and those working
on in the front line but but isn't it an
obvious thing that if we have a massive
backlog and if we have a huge number of
people here that is as you point out are
not living in great conditions not able
to contribute to society
an obvious thing to do would be to stop
any more joining that that list of
people and those people in that
situation so deterrent is key to this is
it not but we've seen that the parents
don't don't work
um although Rwanda hasn't yet taken off
the ground
um we know that even when there was a
threat it didn't work people were still
arriving you know there are no safe
routes to get here and we know that most
of the people who cross the channel
around 91 of people have come from
countries where they are you know they
are almost guaranteed to get Asylum and
people from Afghanistan people from
Syria people from Eritrea where we know
this horrendous human rights abuses so
why not because we just allow
some form of safe routes you know
there's many ways of doing that but
rather than forcing people to cross the
channel particularly people from places
like Afghanistan who have been promised
safety in this country but who are
unable to to actually now
um take advantage of their systems um so
we know that people who cross the
channel most of them are people who
would get Asylum
um anyway so it's just up to us to make
sure that the process works but you say
that but the recent reports about the
number of people who are coming from
Albania which of course is not at War it
says that the number of of people
seeking Refuge from there is higher at
the moment than those from countries
currently at War are conflict like
Afghanistan and of those of albanians
who are coming here to seek Asylum half
are granted Asylum which is still a
large number but half arms which does
suggest that there is the issue of
illegal immigration from countries where
there are not Wars is an issue
um I think it's interesting to look at
actually statistics and yes we know
there's been an increase of people from
Albania and we also know that there's
good reasons for people to travel from
Albania um I should say around 50 of
them do end up getting Asylum which is
it's still a very large number however
in in August
um the home office stats themselves
actually revealed that the top
nationalities of people making Boat
Crossings include people from
Afghanistan Eritrea and Syria and 90 97
of their claims are successful so I do
feel as though they're kind of um we
desperately need to support people from
from Albania who do want to come here or
who do need to come here sorry but I do
feel it's been um pushed as a bit of a
wedge issue from the government to
detract from from the you know the
horror of what's really happening
okay Jenny Regan from IMAX very good to
talk to you today thank you thank you